Next up, let's have a look at Overlaying Materials.
Now, this is new in Unreal Engine version 5,
so you might not have seen this before,
but it really is a great way of doing a lot of things,
which originally was quite hard to do.
You've seen how we needed to create
dynamic material instances in order to create effects,
or we could use the Post-Process Volume.
In this, we created
these effects that you can see here,
which is like a track and checker pattern.
It works on skeletal meshes, standard meshes,
can even function as an X-ray material.
I'll show you how to do that in a little bit.
But the great thing about this is it's the same material
and you can see that the material below it
is not interfered with.
So this can be applied on any specific mesh
and you'll still be able to see the material below.
Now, this is useful because if you were to program
all of your effects into a material,
you'd have to write it into the master material
and the material that it came with.
And this could make it, firstly, very, very complicated.
It means that a lot of people
need to work on one material
and there might be a bunch of efficiency concerns.
So achieving something like this,
especially if you have some areas of transparency and stuff,
this is a lot easier by using these overlay materials.
Now, they can be simpler to use.
If you look at a mesh,
you'll see that we have our standard material slot,
but we also have a overlay materials slot.
Let me just search for it here.
Overlay materials.
And if I was to remove this,
it would just go back to being a normal overlay material.
And if I place the material in, it will affect it.
Even with this skeletal mesh,
even though this has two material slots,
it still only has one material slot for the overlay.
And that's really quick and straightforward to use.
So another thing that's usefully built in here,
we can set the overlay material max draw distance.
So we can have this material turn off.
So if I was to set this to just, let's say 1,000,
and as I move further away,
we should see that that stops displaying.
And you can only do that when you're in game mode.
So you have to push G in order to see this,
and see the material just switches off
at a certain distance.
And that's really useful as an optimization,
especially if one of something like this is very complicated
and you don't want to calculate it
when it's a small three sprites tall in the distance.
So that's how you would add an overlay material on.
Let's look at the creation of one.
So next up, I'm going to go into exercise four here.
And we can see that it will highlight a material
that's called M underscore overlay.
So what I'd like you to do is to open this up
and you should get a material which looks like this.
Now we're going to recreate that checkered pattern one
quite quickly.
So what we've got here is we can use the surface.
We could use other methods as well,
but we're going to go with surface for this one.
And first thing that I want to do
is set an emissive color.
So I want this to go up.
So I'm going to hold down three,
plug this in, and I'll make this one red.
So I'll make the color that we're doing this in red.
Now, next up, I'm going to use a texture top.
So if I hold down T and left-click,
that will give me a texture sample.
And in the dropdown at the bottom here,
I'm going to search for checkers.
You can see that we have a checkered noise pattern here
and I'll use that.
And I know, I think we can use green in this instance
and plug that into the opacity mask.
You can see that suddenly our sphere or cube
is now a lot of it is opaque.
Now that works fine, but I want to do some extra stuff
to make this look better.
So the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to use a pan.
So if I hold down P and left-click,
that's going to give me a panino.
I'll plug that into the UVs.
Now, this is going to move the texture across the UVs.
What I've opted for is to just put one in both the U,
the X and the Y axis.
You can now see that it is moving here up and to the left.
Now this is too large for me.
So I'm going to want to shrink this texture down.
And the way that we would do that is,
the first thing is we would need the texture UVs
for the model.
So if you hold down the U key and left-click,
that's going to give you the texture coordinates.
And then if I hold down M and left-click,
that's going to give us a multiply.
If I plug these in, we'll just multiply this by 10.
That will make this 10 times smaller
and it'll move a lot slower.
So that works quite well.
Okay, so this is the okay material.
There's one more thing that I'd like to do
before we leave this,
and that's the world position offset.
Now, one of the problems that you might get
when you're working with overlay materials
is that it would clash with the model
that's already there.
So because it might be fighting for the same location,
there might be a little bit of sort of cutting in and out
and it wouldn't look how you want it to look.
Now, what I would suggest is if you want to,
is to just push the UVs out a little bit
by using the world position offset.
So in order to do this, what I would do is right-click
and I would search for Vertex Normals World Space, WS.
And then hold down M for a multiply.
I'm going to multiply it just by about 0.3
and plug that into the world position offset.
So all that's going to do
is it's going to push all of the vertices out
just a small amount on the normals of the vertices,
just so we make sure we don't get a clash.
I'll apply and save.
And now if I jump back into the level,
if I search for these, I'm typing overlay,
I'm going to just drag my overlay material in.
And you can see that on all of these meshes,
it will show through, it will automatically be updated.
Now there's a couple of other things
you might want to do at this point.
You can hype up, we can multiply up the emissive possibly
so that it is a lot brighter.
Can change the shading model so that it is,
change the shading model so that it is additive
under the blend mode.
It's because we're now not plugged in
the opacity correctly here.
And that just gives us a bit of a more of a glowing effect
and it's not terribly expensive.
And so that's one option that we have there.
Now, how do we get this to show through?
Like with an X-ray before,
we can get this to show through what's in front of it.
And how we would do that is if we've actually come
into the material again,
I'm going to change the blending mode to translucent.
And as soon as we're in translucent,
there is, if we type in depth,
we have an option to disable the depth test.
And what that is, is we have occlusion culling,
which is built into the engine.
And that means it won't draw a pixel
when there's something else in front of it.
Now, if we disable this depth test,
it's never gonna know if it's in front
or behind something.
So we will draw it regardless.
It needs to be translucent.
You'll now see that all of these models
now show through the background.
So that's just a short exercise showing you
how you can create an overlay material and apply it.
I'm just going to undisable that simply because
I don't want to be seeing that in the corner
every time I move around the world.
But let's have a look at some examples.
So I'm now going to come on to slide 13.
Let's have a look at how you might use
or implement this within the game.
So now we've seen these before,
these simple sort of balls on a pedestal.
And what they do is when you get close enough to them,
they cast to the third person character
or check it's a third person character.
And if it is, it will set the overlay material
on the target, on the skeleton mesh.
So it's as straightforward as this.
All you need to do is set a new overlay material
or remove the overlay material.
So if you wanted to unmesh, you could set overlay,
set the overlay material to nothing and it would go away.
So this will allow you to turn on and off the materials
or apply it to anything.
It's the same method regardless.
It just has to be onto the mesh.
So let's demonstrate this.
So all there are is just a couple of different effects
that you can check out.
So the first one is an overlay,
which is demonstrating the outline.
Now this is done by pushing it backwards
and using custom depth.
It's a bit jittery as you move,
but when you're still, it looks very good.
Next one up is a kind of a sort of force field,
some electrical bolts, fire, ice, and some tar.
So you can see how these kinds of things can be applied
and they can be applied to any meshes.
They can be guns, skeletal meshes, anything.
But it's very, very quick to get them on
and very easy to remove.
Only one can ever be applied at one time.